Copywriting is dead. [laughter] I'm just
kidding. That's the stupidest thing I've
ever heard. But how you make money with
copywriting has completely changed. But
in this video, I'm going to give you
seven easy, not so obvious ways for you
to make 100K or more with copywriting.
By the way, my name is Alan Drau. I've
sold over $2 million with copywriting.
And I have over 10,000 followers across
my socials in email who study my stuff
every day. Copywriting is what I do all
day long. All right, let's jump right
in. Starting with number one, emails for
ecom brands. This is definitely one of
the most accessible ways to make a lot
of money with copywriting. If you have
four clients, just four clients paying
you $2,500 per month to write emails for
ecom brands, you will make 10 grand a
month. That's 120 grand a year. If I
were you, I would do unlimited emails
for them. Three, four, five a week.
Price yourself really accurately at the
$2,500 mark. Write whatever they want.
Add text, SMS. It's honestly, it's not a
crazy amount of work. Four clients is a
really good balance. And ecom brands
need retention and email managers now
more than ever. They're selling more
than ever. They're growing fast. Huge
niche for you to make some really good
money with. Number two is landing pages.
One of the big hurdles in the past with
landing pages is that you would give a
bunch of copy to the client and they
would have to inject your copy into
their landing page. And either they
don't want to do that or they don't want
to hire somebody else to then design it.
and that whole project is a mess. But
nowadays with websites like Wix and
Squarespace and Framer, they have AI
prompting for design. Meaning you could
literally put like your Google doc in,
tell it how you want it to be designed,
use one of their templates, and it'll
literally inject your copy into AI
prompted design templates. It's kind of
wild. And so now you as a copywriter can
package your service as doing full-blown
landing pages with the promise of high
conversion. Meaning, I'm going to write
copy that is for sales for you to sell
your products and services that will
convert high. And you can do all the
work. You can do the design, you can do
the copy, all that stuff because you can
use AI to prompt a design for you. But
you can use your brain for the copy. You
can charge anywhere between like 3 to 10
grand depending on the size of the
projects that you're doing. That is a
completely fair rate for full-blown high
converting landing pages. one to two of
those a month and that is a six-figure
income for you as a copywriter. Number
three, Tik Tok and Meta Ads. You can go
to Facebook's ads library. Literally go
to Google, type in Facebook ad library,
and you could search a bunch of brands
that you really like and see if they are
running ads. Facebook ads library will
not only tell you if they're running
ads, it will show you the ads that they
are running. Then you could screenshot a
bunch of the ads that they were running,
rewrite it for them, reach out to them
and say, "Hey, I dare you to AB test my
ad against your ad and see which one
converts higher." And one of the offers
that you can make for those clients that
if your copy does convert higher is you
can offer a rev share deal on increased
attribution. Meaning these guys are
already running ads, which means they're
probably already making money from their
ads. You could say, "Hey, if you're
making a h 100red grand a month from
these ads through your sales, I get 10%
of whatever is beyond 100 grand." So,
let's say your ads make them 200 grand a
month because your ads are that much
better. Well, now you get 10% of the 200
grand per month as long as you keep
writing ads for them. This kind of
revshare performance-based copy is
really great for people with high skill
and who are willing to take the risk for
massive rewards on the end. I've
personally done this and got some of the
biggest checks in my career. I would not
sleep on rewriting ads for big brands
because they are spending thousands and
thousands of dollars to get them in
front of people. They will pay thousands
of dollars if you get them to perform
better. All right. Number four is you
could do a paid newsletter. This means
you can write your own content on social
media about whatever you want to talk
about. It could be golf. It could be
guitar. It could be EDM music. It could
be desks, tech, doesn't matter. Anything
you want to talk about, you write
content on social media that builds a
following. You move that following to an
email list and you bribe that email list
to start paying you a subscription to
your paid newsletter. If you run a paid
newsletter that costs just $10 a month,
you need 880 people paying you $10 a
month to make a h 100red grand a year at
a 10% conversion rate. That means you
need an email list of about 9,000
people. Estimate about 12 to 18 months
to build a list that size. But that is
now monthly recurring revenue that you
get on a guaranteed basis forever. The
front-end work takes longer, but the
backend reward is so much better. This
is a great way to set yourself up for a
six-figure income by working this year
and reaping the benefits for many years
to come. Which leads me to number five.
Instead of a paid newsletter, you could
do a paid community like me. I run a
paid community called Copy Creator,
where I teach copywriters like you how
to build their own business online using
social media, email list, and selling
digital assets. Exactly like I was
talking about with the paid newsletter,
except I teach it via paid community.
One of the benefits to a paid community
is not just the relationship you have
with your people, the conversations, the
assets, things like that, but you can
also charge more. My paid community is
$50 a month. I've seen other people
charge $90 a month, $150 a month,
depending on the problem that you solve
for your target market. So, for me, at
$50 a month, $220 members is a
six-figure income. 220 people. That is
something that again will take a lot
more front-end work, 6 12, 18 months to
build, but then you get the long-term
rewards for many, many years to come. Or
how about this? Number six, ghost
riding. I've not been a huge fan of
ghostriting for social media content,
per se, until right now. Because never
in my life have I seen more AI slop than
ever on social media platforms, which is
actually creating higher demand for real
copywriters who can write high
converting genuine human sounding
content. And so instead of flocking to
AI to write a bunch of stuff for you,
connect and niche yourself down as a
true copywriter who understands the
craft and can write high-erforming,
high-converting social media content
that grows followers, gets email
subscribers, and helps thought leaders
and CEOs and things like that, get their
ideas out into the world. I would price
this similarly to like the ecom email
pricing. Maybe 2,000 to 2500 bucks a
month, four to five clients max. Boom,
there's your 100K. And last one, number
seven, this one's going to throw you for
a loop. Watch this. Launch a nocode SAS.
This is something I've been personally
exploring myself for about a year now
because with tools like Replet and AI,
you can actually prompt AI to code an
entire software as a service SAS product
for you. I saw somebody do this who made
a habit tracker, but made the habit
tracker function like a video game where
you level up as you build your habits
and you get stats, rewards. Felt like
Pokémon. Now they're like a $25,000 a
month, you know, SAS. But here's where
the copyrightiting comes in is these
products, these software as a services,
the product is scalable, but they don't
know how to get the word out, the
marketing. Well, you are a copywriter.
You can write the ads, the emails, the
landing pages, the social media organic
content to then sell this product after
you build it. So you can make your own
software using AI to code the thing for
you. And then you build a social media
following, an email list, and all this
with your copywriting skills to sell
your software product. That's kind of a
backdoor way to be a really cool
marketer, but for your own business. So,
let's quickly recap. Number one is
emails for ecom brands. Number two is
landing pages with AI design. Number
three is Tik Tok and meta ads. Number
four is a paid newsletter. Number five
is a paid community. Number six is
ghostriting. And number seven is a no
code SAS. Those are seven ways that you
can make 100 grand or more by being a
copywriter. I hope that was helpful. And
if you found a lot of value from this
video, I ask please just take a minute,
hit the like button down below and
subscribe to the channel. It tells me
that you want me to make more content
like this. It's just two buttons.
Literally like and sub. It's two
buttons. Takes you two seconds. Two
seconds to support my channel. I
appreciate it. And before you go, heads
up, hit a link in the description below.
I've got a bunch of free stuff for you.
Copywriting catalyst 63 cash cow
copywriting tips, a free guide that you
can read to be an explosive copywriter.
I've also got things like my hundred
hook templates for you, my cold outreach
system, and a whole bunch of other stuff
on all.com/stuff.
Grab whatever you want. It's all free.
Enjoy. I hope it helps you and I will
catch you on the next